i spent a little time once a while
thinking about
now i'm a scientist doing really well
and
i know the theory about development and
how body parts form but that it's
actually taking place and it's actually
a young kid that is overwhelming
my name is oliver
i'm from denmark and i work at the max
planck institute for molecular genetics
in berlin
most people know about genes are in your
dna
and what usually happens with your dna
is that it's made into rna
and it has been believed for many years
that there are 20 000 genes in the human
genome but for the non-coding rnas it
looks like there are a hundred thousand
genes so that essentially means that
with the discovery of non-coding rnas
we have found five times as many genes
in human as we thought there was
it's this
discovering the unknown
everyday working with something that
might reveal something nobody ever seen
before
that's exciting it's like a big puzzle
having a research group at the max
playing institute it really burst your
creativity because you have
currently has three people in addition
to me in my lab that means they can do
three times as many things i can do and
i'm putting
as much effort as possible into making
that a success
recently my wife and i had a little
daughter and of course that's
becoming a major focus too i guess i
sleep a little less but it works out
pretty well
i like to take my bike
it's fast it's convenient you wake up
i thought before i came to germany that
all germans would stick to the rules the
germans were very correct
and apparently that doesn't apply to
traffic they don't care about you they
care about their car
of course i would like to be a father
who's present and of course if you have
to look at the job of course it takes
time and in the long run i probably have
to put in more hours than right now
but it also inspires you i mean it's
really really hard to get
new fantastic ideas if you're stressed
and tired and working all the time if
you're happy
if you feel good if you do things you
really like when you're not at work
it really inspires you in the end it's
really beneficial for your research
program too